(soft, mellow guitar music)
- [Karl] When you're
on the trail that long,
you don't really think about
how long is it gonna take me
to get to somewhere or
how fast am I going,
you're thinking about,
don't get yourself hurt.
(lively, bouncy guitar music)
My name is Karl Meltzer, and
I am an ultra-marathoner.
- We did 36 miles today--
- Yeah, it was a pretty weak day, but--
No one's ever been this far in 10 days.
I just recently broke the
Appalachian Trail record
from Maine to Georgia, it's 2,189 miles,
and I completed that in 45 days,
22 hours and 38 minutes,
beating the previous record
by just a little under 10 hours.
Total mileage average per day
for that 46 days would be 47.6.
The AT is not a walk in the
park; it's a hard trail.
You really have to have a team;
it's not just the one guy runnin'.
It's really the crew who, if
they're not perfect for you,
then it really won't be successful.
(daunting orchestral music)
I think the Appalachian Trail,
not only is it very popular
and iconic, but it's also very difficult.
Now it's all down hill and easy.
I am concentrating on my
foot placement all the time,
so two hours goes by like
nothin', just because I'm zoned,
I'm zoned out.
I slammed my head into the
ground a number of times
and it beats you down,
you have to expect that,
but you can beat it too as long as you
just keep persevering and
fighting through the issues
that you're going to have.
The last day, I ran 85 miles.
My body was so amped and ready to be done
that it didn't matter
really how far it was.
I felt the same at mile
80 as I did at mile 10.
You're just numb at that point really.
This is where all the fun is.
It's important for people
to know that the AT
is a special place and
it should be protected.
It's a trail for one who wants to gain
fellowship with nature,
no matter whether you're
running it, whether you're walking it,
whether you're taking 10 years to do it,
when you walk that trail, you
have a vibe, and you feel it.
Every year someone else
gets a little bit faster.
Someone will break my record for sure.
It might come this year, I don't know.
I'm still gonna be
happy because I gave it
everything I had.
I think that's what's important.
(lively, bouncy music)
(chiming reverberation)